>>>DANIEL FRIEDMAN: All right. Hello and welcome everyone.
It is Active livestream number 360
and it's January 13,
2022. Welcome to actinF Lab.
We are a participatory online lab that
is communicating, learning, and
practicing applied active inference.
You can find us at the links here on
this slide. This is a recorded and an
archived livestream, so please provide
us with feedback so that we can improve
on our work. And also, if you're
watching Along Live, please write any
comments or questions you have in the
live chat. All backgrounds and
perspectives are welcome here and cell
be following good video etiquette for
live streams. And thanks, Bleu, for
helping a lot with those slides and for
coming on because this will be a fun pop
up. Go to Activeinference.org
to learn more about how to participate
in any of the lab activity or bring some
new idea to the lab.
Okay, here we are in livestream number
36 in the second half of January 2022,
and the goal is to learn and discuss
this paper by Matt Sims and Giovanni
Pezzulo from 2021. The paper is called
Modeling Ourselves what the Free Energy
Principle Reveals about Our Implicit
Notions of Representation. And as
with all dot zero videos, the video is
an introduction for some of the ideas
and a hasty review. So it's not a review
or a final word. We're going to have the
upcoming two weeks to talk more about
this paper and hopefully talk to some of
the authors or any other people who are
interested in this idea and get involved
if you want to talk about the paper. So
let's just start with saying hello and
an introduction and then what we were
excited to read about the paper. I'm
Daniel, I'm in California and was
excited to read set another paper on
representations and the FEP because it
feels like we had a stretch back there
of five in a row or something. What
about you, Bleu?
>>>BLEU KNIGHT: I'm Bleu in New Mexico, and I
really enjoyed Matt Sims paper on
symbiosis that we did a while ago. And I
thought this paper was really neat and
really a clear elucidation of the
different categories of representation
and how, like, there's overarching,
like representation and non
representation and then several
different layers within that. So I
thought it broke it down in a really
clear and concise way, even though it's
a lot of material to digest.
>>>DANIEL: You want to ask the big question?
Sure. The big question of the article
was can the free energy principle help
us advance or even resolve the long
lasting debate on internal
representation in philosophy of mind?
It's a long lasting debate. So this is
like the zeros because it's clearly a
topic you could spend a lot of time on.
So that's our disclaimer. It's a
long standing debate. But here's kind of
a meme slide. So it's the first section
of this paper right below the title. It
has this question from Walt Whitman and
it says hold it up Sternly. See this?
It sends back who is it? Is it you?
And then here are several different
images. And just think about your
perception of these images and the
cultural significance that you might
attach to them. Or the way that black
and white pixels or gray pixels on a
screen give the illusion of depth or
mind you of an emergence that you've
never had. So that's kind of trippy and
representation gets at some of those
issues that's one nonphilosophical
take on it. What are they going to aim
to do in this debate which we're going
to sketch out the sides of in this
talk or I guess this discussion?
Do you want to read it Bleu or sure.
The authors argue that even if the FEP
can't solve this long standing debate,
it can play an invaluable role in
revealing our hidden assumptions about
the very notion of representation and
can create some common ground to discuss
and negotiate them. So they say our
general strategy is to use the FEP for
concept clarification of different
notions of representation. We work
backwards from representational or
internal representation interpretation
of the FEP's constructs to the various
notions of representation that motivate
those interpretations. So they claim
that it emerges from their analysis that
the FEP has been or can be used to
implement various kinds of computational
models which satisfy the requirements of
certain theories of representation.
>>>BLEU: Hence, the question of whether or not
the FEP entails representations depends
on what notion of representation one
uses in the first place. We're going to
unpack that a lot, but just wanted to
give the first coat of paint on what
they're aiming and what they claim to
do. So I'll read the first half. The
abstract predictive processing theories
are increasingly popular in philosophy
of mind. Such process theory often gain
support from the free energy principle
FEP a normative principle for adaptive
selforganized systems. >>>DANIEL: Yet there is a
current and much discussed debate about
conflicting philosophical
interpretations of FEP. For example,
representational versus
representational. Here we argue that
these different interpretations depend
on implicit assumptions about what
qualifies or fails to qualify as
representational.
>>>BLEU: The next part we deploy the FEP
instrumentally to distinguish four main
notions of representation which focus on
organizational, structural, content,
related and functional aspects
respectively. The various ways that
these different aspects matter in
arriving at representation action
oriented representation, interpretation
of the FEP area discussed. We also
discuss how the FEP may be seen as a
unified view where terms that
traditionally belong to different
ontologies. For example, notions of
model and expectation versus notions of
autopilsis and synchronization can be
harmonized. However, rather than
attempting to settle the
representationalism versus non
representationalist debate and reveal
something about internal representation are implication.
This paper demonstrates
how the free energy principle may be
used to reveal something about those
partaking in the debate. Namely, what
are hidden assumptions about internal
representation are assumptions that act
as sometimes antithetical starting
points in this persistent philosophy
debate. There's really two or
three pieces to this paper. There's an
introduction and an abstract. I guess we
can delete that. >>>DANIEL: The first part
introduces a short summary on the free
energy principle and we'll see that
Action Perception Recognition Model.
The bulk of the paper is in these four
segments of each with a dynamics
relationship of internal representation
and the non representational
perspectives. And that section is a lot
like a literature review and a
philosophical taxonomy of different
perspectives and arguments related to
representation and the FEP. And these
four subdivisions. There's then a
addendum on evolutionary function
specifically, and that's apt as nothing
in biology makes sense except in the
light of evolution, as they say. And
then section Five kind of turns a mirror
back on the process and thought,
just like those earlier images with the
mirror. And that's where FEP differences
in perspective are used almost as input
data for theorizing and speculating
about different things, which we'll get
to. So that takes the authors then to
the conclusion. So it's a pretty wide
ranging paper and the keywords that
are here are active inference in free
energy principle, predictive processing,
generative model, internal
representation, action oriented
representation, inactivism forward
model, and Markov blanket's. There's no
single path or single slide that would
do justice to all these keywords. So
we're just going to kind of jump in and
knowing that some people will be really
familiar with some of these terms and
others will be hearing about them for
the first time. So first the big topic
is representation. Now this is just a
quote from the paper. Whether or not
living organisms have or need internal
representation is an old and fiercely
debated topic. So we kind of like
unzipped that citation to add the titles
and the links and just some of the
images from these citations. So if these
topics or any of this body of literature
you feel like is well motivated or well
reasoned or you've never been exposed to
it, that's sort of the continent we're
on. And it is such a large continuum.
So the authors write such a debate is
reiterated within the predictive
processing view. So they're going to
tell the story of representation from
predictive processing as sort of an
implicit starting point from a more
specific and mechanistic angle.
Assuming the FEP is a good model of
living organisms, does it entail the
notion of internal representation or
not? So it's almost like we're
conditioning our analysis, whether it's
a counterfactual or not, on FEP being
used instrumentally. So we're going to
use it just like we would use a ruler,
not by questioning the ruler against
known objects, but by going to unknown
objects and investigating them. So
that's the way Zhat the FEP is going to
be used in this very large scale topic
and complex area of representation. Any
comments? Lu all right, another big
topic and word that comes up in this
paper, but also a lot of other of our
discussions is enactivism. And so
who better to hear it from than the
radicals? So Herek 2014.
I think it's a thesis why radical
enactivism is not radical enough, a case
for really radical inactivism. So take
it up with the author. If this is
oversimplifying or that's kind of the
joke appeal here, it is oversimplifying.
And here we see three different
framework contrasted against each other
cognitivism, radical inactivism and then
really radical inactivism. And cognition
differs from an activism on the top row
in that cognition says basic cognition
is representational and enactivism is
going to be rejecting that claim on all
accounts. And then where this author is
saying that you could even go further
into the inactive camp or forest or
whatever is you could even deny that
linguistic cognition is
representational. So even if it looks
symbolic and it looks like it has some
representational characteristic and it's
the gray zone that makes people go, oh,
okay, maybe there is some redeeming
aspect of representation, you just have
to keep on denying it. So maybe
we can pick that threat up again. But
that's sort of the lay of the land, of
maybe the center and activists, the
moderates and then the extremists Bleu.
Anything? Zhat no. It's so interesting
to really think about representation and
the brain. I mean, coming from
neuroscience, actually okay, I'll add
something coming from neuroscience,
it's interesting to really think about.
>>>BLEU: I mean, the visual cortex is very unique
in the sense that we know that there's
representation that is replicated in the
brain, but everywhere else, it's just
kind of like, you know, we've never
found like the word for apple in the
brain somewhere. Like there's no, like,
apple neurons. So it's just an
interesting I don't know, just a
position, I guess, about representation
and language, thinking about it in terms
of the brain. Also, one really important
aspect that we didn't mention is it's
about action. Like, it is basically
saying that action is related to
embodiment and all these other things,
but enactivism is just focusing on
action and what that means.
>>>DANIEL: All right, free energy principle, which
we're going to spend a lot of the
discussion on. It's an integrative
proposal on adaptive self organizing
systems that remain far from
thermodynamics equilibrium. So that
would be cool if we had one common
framework for things that maybe were far
or close to equilibrium. Currently, we
only have some of those areas of
Faithbase. It starts from the premise
that in order to survive, living
organisms engage in reciprocal action
perception exchanges with their
environment. They must do what they can
in order to remain within a neighborhood
of viable states. That's kind of the
cybernetic regulator insight. Then the
bottom paragraph, the idea is cast in
Bayesian terms by assuming that
biological active state state the priors
of the agents, the states that an agent
prefers to visit become the states that
Bit expects to visit. Hence minimizing
surprise or its longterm average, which
is entropy becomes a primary imperative
for living organisms as it permits them
to counteract an otherwise unavoidable
process of dimension and loss of
integrity, which kind of closes the loop
back with the resistance to dissipation
that was brought up in the beginning.
So this is kind of one FEP boomerang
from starting switch, a focus on
resisting distinctions and then moving
thought, the action of perception loop
to ecological preferences and facts of
the reduction of uncertainty and thus
resisting dissipation.
A partitioning that is natural or
at least complementary to the FEP is the
Markov blanket partitioning. And we've
talked about this in several other
streams, so we won't go into it in too
much detail. This is from 26. And the
Markov blanket condition, at least in
its more narrow technical sense,
is referring to some set of nodes,
representations, statistical variables.
And that set of nodes that make up the
blanket makes some other sets of model,
two other sets of nodes which we can
call the internal and the external
states. It makes those two sets
conditionally independent and the edges
are statistical influence Bleu.
What else would you say about Mark
Friston blanket? They say it here
beautifully. So the blanket states act
as an informational boundary between
internal and external states. And that's
like the simplest way to think about it,
>>>BLEU: right? Like my skin acts as a barrier
between myself and the world. The
blanket access as a barrier.
Yes. Cool. Okay.
>>>DANIEL: Leaving FEP land proper, we can
zoom out to some related topics that
sometimes get brought up in discussions
of FEP but often don't. So first is the
predictive processing framework. This is
drawn from a citation that was in the
bibliography but not sure if it was in
the text Hohwy 2020. And this is a
paper, New Directions in Predictive
Processing. So predictive processing
asserts that perceptual and cognitive
systems engage in prediction error
minimization, enabling approximate
Bayesian perceptual inference. And some,
but apparently not all authors emphasize
action. So Clark and Howie famously and
recently have emphasized that action is
essential to predictive processing in
the form of active inference, where the
system infers its own policies. So
really emphasizing that the predictions
are not just about sensory inputs
but causes of sensory input,
hypotheses about latent unobserved
causes in the world and also one's own
action and policies, what one expects to
do. And there's a really awesome
supplemental file for this paper that
includes a great literature analysis and
a lot of keywords and unique prediction
and lists of empirical evidence. So this
is really awesome work, and it'd be
great to hear from people who study
predictive processing or are more
familiar with it. How theory see it in
relationship to active inference and
FEP,
something that's in the overload of
predictive processing Bayesian
statistical theories, active inference's
is the idea of a generative model model.
So let's recall from DCM
the dynamical causal modeling which
we talked about in the previous weeks
in number 35. And here
in DCM. It is an appealing to
biologically grounded models and
dynamical systems theory to create a
probabilistic generative model of hemo
dynamics fluctuations. So what is a
generative model? It's basically opposed
to a descriptive model. So why would one
use the generative model in statistics?
Because these types of models can be run
in both directions. They can be fit from
data, but they can also be used to
generate data and then they can be used
in different ways because of that
capacity. Lower dimensional generative
models can be very computationally
efficient because they only have to be
updating a few parameters rather than
keeping track of every single data
parameter and then a little bit more on
the interpretive layer or beyond the
merely statistical generative model.
Model capture some of these openended
and creative or complex dynamics that
are associated with action and
perception and recognition model.
Therefore, there are links to not only
the cognitive sciences but also
philosophy and phenomenology. So it's
kind of an idea from statistics that
gets connected to some of the
fundamentals of neuroscience and
philosophy and anything
out of that Bleu. Yes. So just when I
think of the generative model, having
listened to so many people describe it,
my favorite description is almost as
like the recognition model is more
like the hardware or the state space.
>>>BLEU: Then the generative model is like the
software, the action between them, or
like the dominoes and the stock dominoes
and then the cascading wave. Right. So
the dominoes would be the Recognition
model and then the generative model is
the relationship between them, the
cascading wave of dominoes. I always
like to use that analogy, just it's
clear for me. And here's one
more slide from 26 where the idea of
the Mark Cob blanket, which we pulled
from 26 as well is connected to the idea
of a generative model in the section on
predictive processing. >>>DANIEL: And so in this
paper so go check out number 26 or the
paper on Bayesian mechanics to learn
more. But the idea is that it's possible
to use the Markov blanket partitioning
so that there's the blanket states
statistically isolating internal and
external states. And then there might be
some systems where those partitioned
internal states are acting as if they
are doing inference on external states.
So that would be like if I said I'm
going to hold up three fingers and put
it behind my back. And then you had a
generative model that was about what was
the state of that unobserved variable.
And that's something to look more into
from the details on generative model as
with other papers. And that kind of
brings us to our last keyword, which is
active inference. So we'll go into a
little more detail here.
They describe that active inference
agents are selfevident, which is to say
that because minimizing free energy over
time is equivalent to maximizing
Bayesian model evidence or evidence
encoding. In longterm active inference,
agents seek out or generate those
sensory samples that maximize the lower
bound on the evidence for an implicit
model of how their sensory states were
generated. As such, active inference
agents author evidence for their own
continued existence via free energy
minimizing model minimization. So active
inference is using statistics to
operationalize some of the information,
thermodynamics formalisms of the FEP.
So it would be a more narrow
interpretation that Zhat carries no or
little philosophical baggage or claims
to how the world really is. It would be
a more broad or stronger interpretation
to think that this is capturing actual
information dynamics or the actual
thermodynamics relationships of systems.
But the instrumental usage is more of a
statistical similarity or at least
attractability argument. And that is
not without precedent, not even close,
because the variational Bayesian
methods, which minimize or optimize this
quantity called the evidence lower
bound, start maximizing the lower bound
for how good the evidence is. And others
in many places have motivated this
fundamental component of modern Bayesian
statistics from multiple different
areas. And it's kind of like equations
are true, so equations can be linked to
each other. And it's just kind of cool
that these KL divergences as well as
free energy and the information or
description length criterion all align.
And that's not even like an active
synthesis. Applying that to
inference on action is something that is
bringing together a lot of these ideas
from variational Bayesian methods with a
lot of ideas from control theory,
cybernetics enactivism, etc.
And again, we can explore back and find
out which ideas came from where. But
just to keep in mind is Zhat. These
pieces were not tied together by active.
Those are excellent relationships in the
literature. But active does integrate
the free energy principle and that
center meme that they started with,
that things have to resist distinctions
with all of this philosophy and
more quantitative area zhat have to do
with action and perception. And then in
the dot one and dot two cell go more
into the variational and expected free
energy, but kind of wanted to just give
a little thought on active inference.
And if someone has a different thought,
it'd be awesome to hear it as well. But
this paper was very precise and very
subtle in how I thought about some of
these areas. So I think it's really good
to be clear about what we're talking
about in this case.
Okay, onto the paper. All right.
So this is going to be a flow role of
the introduction. There's a growing
consensus in computational and systems,
in neuroscience around the idea. The
brain is a predictive machine which uses
internal or generative models to
continuously generate prediction in
service of prediction, action and
learning. So starting with the idea of
prediction second sentence.
One of the ways Zhat people are studying
prediction in the brain is predictive
processing. So we talked about that a
few minutes ago,
the free free energy principle extending
predictive processing by providing it
with a fundamental principle of adaptive
self organization that's the resist
dissipation meme that isn't
intrinsically within predictive
processing framework which might
describe audio processing in a radar
signal. And so that
union of FEP and predictive processing
are starting to become prominent outside
of systems neuroscience, which might
seem like their natural niche or origin,
but it's also the case that philosophy
in the philosophy of mind are starting
to think about it. And despite
that attention, the authors are arguing
that some of the implication for FEP's
existence remain widely debated. I think
we can agree on that. And they're
going to focus on one of the prominent
discussions that they think is the most
prominent, which is whether the FEP is
representational or representational and
then to what extent. It is also learning
on debates related to internalism action
orientation and activism. So just it's
all over the map. It's a multi
dimensional philosophy force base with
the FEP and it's not totally resolved,
but that's what they're going to go into
in this parse.
Okay.
>>>BLEU: Bleu so they
note here that philosophical discussions
or representation wars about the FEP
have typically been focused on four
aspects of the notion of representation.
So these four aspects are
organizational, structural, content
related or functional. And the
organizational aspects have some
variable inside a system that's
separated from that which it represents.
Outside the system, structural aspects
have representational vehicles that are
structurally similar to the state of
affairs in the world. Zhat they stand
for contentrelated aspects have internal
models that either encode environmental
contingencies or sensory motor
contingencies, specification or
description of how the world is taken to
be in turn analyzed in terms of
correctness or truth conditions. And
>>>BLEU: then the functional aspects support
vicarious use before or in the absence
of external events of internal variables
of a model. Whoa.
Yep, bit is kind of a woe, but this four
field distinction is the structure of
the paper. So we're going to do a few
fun things to help understand this
because it is the contribution and the
structure of the paper. So everyone's
going to interpret all of this in their
own way, which is awesome, but we do
really want to be clear about what the
author's contributions are. >>>DANIEL: So in an
almost unprecedented maneuver, we're
gain to go to the end of the paper first
and then also have the figures out of
order. We're going to start with what we
can learn from this debate. So if you're
not sure if you want to listen to the
next like 40 minutes on going into this
four Bull distinction, you get it up
front. So they're going to review some
of the most prominent philosophical
interpretations of the FEP. They then
summarize those interpretation according
to the four different categories. Zhat
Bleu just red for each of
those categories, they're going to
consider multiple constructs of FEP, so
kind of tools in the FEP toolkit system.
And they're going to argue that
depending on which perspective you take
on which of these categories and which
constructs, you're going to come to
different conclusions about the
representational or representational
nature of the FEP. So it's kind of like
a checkerboard that's their first salvo
is we're going to outline a flowchart
and a grid and a structure, like a
taxonomy of philosophy, ideas related to
this triple dimensional space
of aspects of representation,
constructs of the FEP and then the
categorical variable representational or
non representational claims. And then
the whole second part is saying we're
going to use that three dimensional
phase space to shine a light on one's
own implicit notions of representation.
So that's kind of like the looking in
the mirror strange loop part. But the
first part is more like a philosophical
literature analysis. And their
contribution in figure two is to
make this awesome flow chart.
So this is going to funnel you from the
start in the four different domains,
four aspects, variational, structural
content and function. And then from
those four starting points, kind of like
sorry board, you're going to get
funneled towards representational
or representational FEP, depending on
decisions. And that's what we're going
to unpack in the next sections because
again, it's kind of like trippy
and there's a lot to think about. This
is going to be our map. So it's going to
be at the bottom of all of the upcoming
slides, which of these eight sections
were in. It's like a cube divided in
eight little cubes or two
tetrahedral or some other pattern. But
basically we're going to see whether
we're in like representation camp or non
representation camp and which aspects
we're focused on. And then here's that
table, but it's just the tip of the
iceberg. So how can we organize our
thinking around philosophy and increase
the rigor and the accessibility of
different arguments? Because it can be
difficult sometimes to parse it
in long texts. And so
the authors clearly thought a lot about
this. So it's a really pleasure to read
about it and learn about it. And the
flowchart is a great addition. So that
is going to be our map in the coming
slides,
right? Thanks for making such a
beautiful map. I have to say I had
pasted a whole bunch of these ideas and
tried to categorize them and then Daniel
constructed them into this beautiful
flowchart. Well, they made the flow
chart, I made the grid. The grid.
>>>BLEU: That's what I meant, the grid. The grid.
Before we see the grid in action now,
let's just recall this action perception
loop. And we're not going to go into it
right now, but that's definitely for dot
one and dot two. What are these nodes
and edges and which can and can't happen
and what do they representation. >>>DANIEL: So that
is sort of the partitioning that we're
going to be working within, which we
brought up a little earlier with the
Markov blanket and in a lot of our other
discussions. Okay, so let us start
in this top left square.
So this is the organizational aspect,
the representational perspective.
So the organizational aspect is
describing how variables inside a system
are separated from what it represents
outside the system. So that's like the
architectural take
on representations. I don't know is it
classic representations but internal
representation camp are going to argue
zhat internal states are segregated from
the external world via Markov blanket.
Therefore the brain activity cast as
internal states do represent what it
doesn't have access to Bleu, what do you
think? Or anything else to add on it?
>>>BLEU: Nothing I want to delve into here
because I'm going to save it for that
one. Okay. Okay. In contrast,
there's other people and other
perspectives who are going to,
in the organizational aspect, take a non
representational perspective. And so
philosophers of the ecological and
activity persuasion have approached that
same Markov blanket formalism and
basically framed it in terms of
representational view of the FEP.
>>>DANIEL: Like Yellow Brunerberg's paper, the
anticipating brain is not a scientist
free energy principle from an ecological
and active perspective. So they argue in
those papers, in a lot of papers by
Yellow and others, that just
because you deploy the Markov blanket
formalism it doesn't imply the behavior
of the system is best explained by
inferences generated by an internal
model, the structure of which is
representing that, which is a model of.
So read the papers for more detail. But
it's like,
it's an interesting idea and it was also
interesting to read from this paper that
the restatement of this argument that
these partially informationally
encapsulated systems like we talked
about in 35 are parsimoniously
understood in terms of achieving high
relative mutual information between the
non representational process of
generalized synchrony and Huygens 1673,
the pendulum clock. So you can get like
oscillating pendulums that synchronize
but they don't have representations of
each other. Now maybe you need
representations to do something else but
that kind of gets to that enactivism
radical and activist debate. So we'll go
more into it later. Just kind of cool
old citation and interesting idea.
So based upon the organization of the
system, there area people who say,
yeah, the FEP is representational of
course because the internal states are
isolated or no, because you can get high
mutual information without
representation. All right,
that's like what Dean called nine
o'clocking, it's 09:00.
>>>BLEU: That's general synchrony. Exactly.
There doesn't need to be a
representation of brushing the teeth in
the mind or anything of the reader.
Okay. Onto the second aspect, the
structural aspects. >>>DANIEL: So the question to
be addressed is whether generative
models are structurally similar to their
targets or accuracy descriptions of
external reality or whether models
needn't be accurate but merely adequate
enough to leverage for adaptive behavior
control. So does. It actually need to
representation the thing?
Or can bit be just some other
representation that is
effective enough? So here's the
pro and the con for representational.
On one slot, the top
structural representationalist view
argues that the generative model has to
have some structural resemblance with a
generative process in order to be useful
for control purposes that's really
related to the good regulator theorem
from Cybernetics.
And so the argument there is you're
gain to need the good representation
about it in order to be on the
right page in complex environments.
Others disagree.
So here's one line of argument that the
formal constructs in active inference
and specifically the generative density
G, if it's understood correctly,
according to some authors, it would turn
out to internal representation. Those
authors suggested REM sad at all 2019,
that generative models do not meet the
requirements of structural
representations where some internal
structure replicates some structure of
the generative process. So the
generative model is the organism's model
of action. The generative process is the
actual world out there, the niche that's
giving rise to observations. And so, in
other words, you might be I don't know
if this might be a mal example, but like
to run, you don't need to have an
abstract representation of your own
body. You merely need the
action interactions with your body.
And so this is kind of arguing that the
internal generative density G active
doesn't have to have any resemblance
structure to even the problem which it's
being deployed to solve.
Well, and this always goes to the map
and the territory and active inference
between the map and the territory. So
structural similarity, what does that
mean? >>>BLEU: Right. So how similar?
Is there some metric that you're using
for structural similarity? How similar
is the map of the United States to the
actual United States? Right? And so what
does that even mean? Structure
similarity? Sorry, I'm probably poking
the fire bit. Let's hear
from Alex Kilner or Maxwell
or anyone else who feels really strongly
about this issue because we've had some
fun talks on it before. And it's just I
just like seeing the pro and the con
laid out together. >>>DANIEL: And then the authors
were very.
>>>BLEU: I just like arguing what is the
difference between the pro and the con?
I want somebody to draw the line for me
what is similar and what is not similar.
Enough niche. Okay, now to the third
aspect. So this is the content related
aspects.
>>>DANIEL: Whether the generative models need to
explicitly model the ways external
states produce sensations, aka
environmental models, or the ways that
actions produce sensations or sensory
motor models,
this is very closely related to the
previous aspect. So I think it be
cool to unpack a little more. But
theorem is a little bit of nuance with
sensory motor systems,
which we talked about in several places,
like skilled performance.
And basically this
is just one subargument within this
section, a pro and a Zhang and they're
talking about essentially skilled
performance, how sensory motor models
can afford sophisticated cognitive
processing. And so the first agreement
here is that here comes that same Jelle
Bruineberg 2016 paper the anticipating
brain is not a scientist saying that,
yeah, actually sensory motor loops. If
you're going to trust the story for one
level of analysis, then why are more so
called complex behavior, not just more
complex combinations of modules which
don't appeal to any representational
content? And then the
sensory motor dynamics created by those
models may be progressively internalized
to support mental operations detached
from the sensory motorcycle. So maybe
like walking and chewing gum or
something like that, or maybe think
about like an insect flying or walking
and how much of that is just the shape
of its body in motion and just the way
that the muscles and the joints just
like flex. And so ascribing the total
motion of every joint to cognition
actions just is probably asking
too much of cognition. Unless taking
embodied and morphological computation
as another type of computation and then
firing back for the representationalism
is coming from the area of
schema theory which is where there
is a nucleus of sensory motor models,
but then they're extended to include
external causes of selection. So that
just kind of like a flavor of one of the
subdivates. And it would be good to
discuss, I think, how the structure and
organizational and content related
differ because it is like a nuanced
debate. And so I appreciate how clear
they did make it given that it's murky
waters because these are like four
aspects of a philosophical idea.
Oh, then of course this meme.
Okay, so the embodied cognition
literature has shown some practical
examples of how good control can be
realized using fast and frugal solutions
and very simple models. This is an
example that Dave described on a live
stream just recently. One popular
example is the baseball outfielder
problem or the fact that catching a
moving ball may not require a full model
of the ball's position, velocity and
direction, allowing for trajectory
prediction, but a simpler control
mechanism that only keeps the image of
the ball stationarity on the retina.
Alright, so here on the left, this is
like the physics class model of some
of the parameters. So this is already a
map of the territory. We're not going
into the temperature of the ball and the
wavelength of the grass. So this isn't
like a world model. This is just the
physics reduced model of the physics of
the asymptotic ball in this kind of
idealized settling range. So that's a
lot of parameters like as drawn out
there. And here from this Wired article,
how do people actually catch baseballs?
Here's the apparent ball position as a
function of time and just showing how if
you're in the position to catch the
ball, that there's a simple heuristic
line related to the apparent ball's
position. Whereas Bull that
you're too short or too long to catch
have a very different visual trajectory.
So in other words, an activism is saying
this on the left doesn't have to be the
representation. Zhat would be something
that might satisfy the most formal
representationalist. But then this is
sort of a gray area. Like what if there
is a visual representation of the ball
on the retina? So there is something
that's featuring information about the
real world in an actionable way, but it
is of a totally different type than the
parameters in the physics class. And so
that can get, of course, a little
sticky. So here is us on the Phillies.
We're trying to catch the fly Bull
here's. Friston hitting it out of the
park with the action perception loop and
all the work in this field. So what is
the equivalent? Do we need to have the
physics class model or
is bit possible for us to have some
other type of understanding? Just a
thought. What do you think? Bleu. >>>BLEU: So it
just really makes me think about
blindness, right? And I know that this
seems like a way out there trajectory
bit, we know the physics of our natural
environment. We know it pretty well.
What about when we remove ourselves or
like remove one sense, like remove
vision? Right now we have like a really
different perception of our
environment and we have to completely
retrain through kinesthetic memory where
we are in our environment. If like the
lights go out. I mean, I was without
power for 4 hours the other day in the
middle of the night and I was like
totally freaked out because I live in
the country and there was absolutely no
light, like none. So in that you have
to know where all the things are. So
like, this is a structural map in your
mind of your reality that's really
different from what you're able to
absolutely perceive at that moment.
Just makes me think of that. >>>DANIEL: Nice.
That's just a fun slide.
Various slides. This is still
on the this is I guess on the functional
aspects. Alright, so here's the
functional perspective or the functional
aspects of representation. Another way
to address the issue of what a
representation is and what it is not is
by asking what functional internal
representation play within a
hierarchical architecture. So this is
the function, kind of the pragmatics of
the representation. What it does. An
idea zhat dates back to at least PSA
four is the idea that representation
should vicariously stand for something
external in its absence and afford
vicarious operating plant mental
operations using an internal vehicle
that are executed before acting on the
external preference of the vehicle or
even when the external reference is
absent. So it is able
to be cause and effect within
the mental ecosystem like we'll see
from these examples. Consider mentally
whether one would enjoy eating a pizza
with no pizza in sight. So be like okay,
think of a pizza. Do you want to eat
that? Now imagine that type of food that
I previously mentioned and then what
type of restaurant it is and what
equipment do they have in the kitchen,
like an oven or something like that? So
there's something that's being
functionally carried forth in that
cognitive sequence. Can that be uniquely
explained, predicted, controlled,
designed with just sensory motor loops?
This functional role of representation
has been expressed in terms of whether
the agent's internal operations are
detached from its action perception
cycle and hence autonomously generated
versus determined or sustained by
external stimuli. So if something were
just repeatedly causing visual stimuli
and Zhat were causing, like, sort of
unaware movements, that would not be one
category of phenomena. But what about
going on a walk and remembering a five
digit number by just chanting it to
yourself? Is that sensory motor?
How is that playing out? And when
cognition is playing a functional role
seemingly uncoupled from the action
perception loop, which is probably not
exactly how Piaget framed it, but that's
what that notion is. And so within
the functional aspect, the FEP is
leading on to ask, what functional roles
do internal models play during free
energy minimization? So just like the
memorizing, the number was like a cause
and effect of a cognitive environment.
Is it the case that the FEP is featuring
things that are also causes and effects
in the cognition environment?
And does that resemble vicarious
operations in the classical phase based
account of representation? And again,
it's going to be the dot one, the dot
two when we go into the variational and
the expected free energy. But that's
like, the big picture on the functional
aspect is, do these variables play
functional roles in a way that's
uncoupled from the immediacy of action
and perception? I hope I represented
that because I'm also not sure how that
one okay.
Anything to add? Bleu? So I think about
it in a different way. Like, you're
walking down a path and remembering a
five digit number, but like, I don't
know, something Zhat probably resonates
with Sasha or like anybody else that
does extensive Zhat lab research. Zhat,
you've done. So it surprise me that it
doesn't bring its mind for you is,
like, thinking about your action. >>>BLEU: It's
like a dry run of your experiments the
next day. Do I have the tubes I need,
the enzymes I need, the reagents I need?
Where are all these things located?
When it's a really important experiment,
like hit or miss, it has to be done now
or never. Like, which you know that
there are some that are like, that it's
important to go through and make sure
that you've got, like, a cognitive
representation. Like, you build it and
so it's fresh in your mind for when you
absolutely, like, execute the
experiments. And so that's like,
instead of walking down a path thinking
of a five digit number, how about,
like, planning, like, the sensory motor
planning of executing a series of
experiments. It brings that to mind for
me. Yeah, great.
And that makes me think, like,
let's just say it's a 1 hour experiment
that you're thinking about. >>>DANIEL: Now,
does the motor pattern firing associated
with pushing your thumb down on the
pipette, does Zhat get engaged during
the prospective planning of that event?
Who knows to zhat extent. But that's
kind of what's at play here. If there's
a totally disjoint neural phenomena
associated with the prospective
planning, then the inaction we're in one
camp of representationism. I don't even
know which side of the line anymore.
But then if you do have that thumb
neural firing pattern, like it's just
like sped up or just shortened or
something, maybe we're in a different
area. So let's return to these
ideas because, again, it's very nuanced
and it's just great the authors laid it
out as simply as they did because this
is clearly a lot of literature to go
through. So that was the eight,
the four times two. I won't even go
Hinton it, but four times two. And
that's the bulk of the paper. And then
there was this addendum section on
representation as an evolutionary
function. So similar to other cognitive
functions like working memory,
planning, cognitive control and
attention, or perhaps even to functions
like flying or swimming. Representation
here intended in the sense of affording
vicarious operations and detachment from
the current action perception cycle,
may be an evolutionary function. So it's
kind of like when people argue that
consciousness has an adaptive role and
that the origination of consciousness
could be scaffolded or nurtured or
selected for once it arose. This is a
little bit less phenomenological and
more cognitiveist or computationalist
with respect to saying how
representation might play an
evolutionary role. So let's just imagine
that there was this detachment between
the action perception role and planning.
Like here's Pokemon and I'm Ants.
Imagine if they're able to perceive
the polarization of light or the
intensity of the light or the humidity
and then have something like a
representation that helps them assess
whether it's appropriate to forage on
that day. That is going to be a more
adaptive nest mate for the colony. Does
the colony have a representation? What
level is the representation existing at?
Is it the direct target of selection
or is it arising from selection on other
units? What do you think? Bleu?
We were just talking about this,
right? >>>BLEU: Is the niche the Internet,
right? Is that like the meta
representation of humanity? Like the
web? That's it. So I wrote that here
and things to discuss and the dot one or
dot two is external representation.
Like, how do you offload this
representationalism into the niche?
>>>DANIEL: Awesome question. And I also,
I think, probably subconsciously was
thinking about that. Like the image on
the right is a trail, a truth trail that
the Pokemon mermax use. And so it's like
it's not going in every direction in
this colony. It's only going in one
direction, it's along a tree. So it's
kind of accentuating this natural
pattern in the generative process in the
niche. But then now that is like an
externalized prior for foragers
that's based upon the clearing of grass
and then they're less likely to go like
walk order the midden pile and forage in
a different direction. But then it does
happen, so the trail does move.
So it's like interesting topics.
Yes. Thanks for writing down about the
internet. Okay, let's continue through a
few of these last ideas and I'm glad
that we're moving briskly through this
long paper.
Okay, so let's keep thinking about that
detachment of representation from the
action perception loop they write. In
other words, full fledged decoupled
representational capacities might shade
off, which I wasn't even sure what the
origins were. Maybe it's used in God for
Smith 96 into other cognitive or minimal
cognitive processes, the dynamics of
which are increasingly more coupled to
the environment through action sensory
perception. So it's like being at a
levels of cognitive complexity where you
can spin up other active entities or
like the queen as a reproductive ant is
spinning off cognition but not
reproductive nest mates. Therefore,
when taking functional role as
contextualized by evolutionary function
as a criterion for identifying when
recourse to representation is warranted
in explanation, which is a very
complexity linguistic clause.
But we're finding out when
representation is warranted, the
criteria for that would be evolution
shaping function. So it's a lot like
saying nothing in biology makes sense
except in light of evolution. And then
under those settings it is possible to
interpret at least some processes, the
ones that involve vicarious variables
related to minimizing free energy.
Under that context, the author
suggests that could drive the kind of
self organization that FEP would
describe as representational. So it's
layered, but it's very fascinating
because it is just like you had Majid
Bleu with our niche, but it's
like just stacking rocks on
top of each other. It's resisting
disorder, it displays culture, but those
rocks don't have a self modeling
capacity. It's like uni
variational multi scale integration the
other Sims paper whereas here we have
like a human who is part of their niche,
has made another adaptive active
inference entity and now they're engaged
in this reciprocal multi scale
integration. And so I
think the authors might be suggesting
that there's aspects of this settling
point might be described as or
might be warranted to utilize
representation in the exploration. What
do you think?
>>>BLEU: So I always wonder whether we should
talk about multiscale integration or
thinking thought other minds in terms of
translating into the niche.
And how do you decide whether we're
interactions? As I Dean, I guess there's
always this thinking through other mind
aspects of, you know, we live like
stigma jack traces in our niche
environment and then they're picked up
by other people or is it really
multiscale integration, like in terms of
you and I are connecting and forming a
bigger unit. I always and this is we
were just talking about this like ten
minutes before we got here today. So
this is something to me that's like this
fundamental paradox. Like I don't know
how to distinguish these.
I guess that shared informational
channel always comes through the niche
environment, whether it's the Internet
or some knowledge artifacts like a
scientific paper or a computer or
something else. But my relationship with
you or any human is always through the
niche environment. There's always that
filtration and whether it's in real time
like we are here now, or sequentially.
Even if it's so called in person, it's
mediated by vibrating air molecules now
it's intermediated through routers and
such it's utilization of
the niche. And I think this is just
raising a super fascinating question.
>>>DANIEL: Cell yeah, thanks for raising this.
We'll discuss that and then this is like
saying it's one thing to talk through
the tin cans. That's like using the
direct passive active inference agents
even if we could describe the tin can as
perception and action. But now what if
there's a chat bit that's intermediate
between the two of us or it's
translating between two different
languages. Then where does that put the
status of that entire cognitive system?
How does it influence thinking through
other minds when the intermediaries are
passive versus adaptive active inference
entities? So nice questions. All right.
This is the part which also will unpack
more in the one and two. This is kind
of the wormhole strange loop turning
the mirror back on itself part. So the
authors write in much the same manner as
arriving at internal representation or
internal representation interpretation
of FEP. So that's the whole sections
that we just spent the whole time on
like everything within the realm of
actually using the FEP, not taking
it as an unknown, but taking the FEP as
an instrument and then using it to ask
whether it is representation or not on
those different aspects. So now we're
going to put that behind us and consider
arriving at FEP as a synthesis.
Depends on which representational
criteria are assumed when either
considering FEP central constructs or
considering specific cognition phenomena
through the lens of a process theory
under FEP. Hence, in the end, the debate
about FEP may reveal more about us, our
criteria for representation and our
interests in particular facets of
cognition than it does about internal
representation status of the FEP. So JFK
is out there somewhere. Ask not what the
FEP can do for you,
it's saying because you can be all over
the map. Maybe all of these sectors are
in play and all the perspectives in each
of those aspects. That means that
somebody's posterior confidence in
different claims is
probably better reflecting of their
prior and update process than some sort
of objective stance or consensus reality
about what the FEP is. As if it
could be such a thing independent of how
it specifically deployed, as we talked
about with model based science and Majid
Beni. So this is a very nice
point,
I think both. Yeah. I mean,
fundamentally, the FEP is a
representation. I mean, it is our
representation, our model. I mean, it
might be the one that we employ with
which to it might be an instrument, or
it might be a real thing, but still
we represent FEP, like, with equations
and with ideas and memes and I don't
know. >>>BLEU: I mean, we impute our
representation on it all the time. So
whether it is representation itself or
we represent the FEP, but there's some,
like there's some, like, play there.
It's integrated with representation all
the time, like linguistically or other
or maybe not. Maybe I'm not a radical
enactivism enough, or what was the
radical inactivist? Really? >>>DANIEL: Radical?
Yeah. Well, I'm sure we'll talk
more about it. So just the conclusion
and then a few last points.
So, nine sentences in the conclusion.
One, they looked at four different
aspects of representation. Two,
understanding which side of which line
to come down on was complicated because
the FEP appeals to multiple constructs
that don't prior seem to be
strongly linked or naturally linked.
Like, it's unclear whether one begets
the other or whether they constantiate.
And that's the kind of work that we're
really interested in, in the ontology
project and in the knowledge corpus
engineering, of course, in the.edu
organizational unit of actinF Lab. So
the FEP appeals to multiple constructs,
and those model can be constructed in
various ways. So it's good to clear up
representation into these fourfold
distinctions. However, it's complexity
still, because the FEP is kind of like a
plurality in and of itself. Three,
they argue that depending on how you
think about things, you're going to
think about things differently. They
then turn the mirror back and suggest
that that's an opportunity. It's a
challenge, but it's also an opportunity
to reflect upon how we value
representation and different features in
our model selection related to the main
part of this paper. And then they sort
of salvage the utility of FEP,
whether heads FEP wins, tails not FEP
loses, because the FEP can be heuristic.
So, like, kind of good for functionally
or pragmatically for philosophy of mind,
even if not so much to settle the
dispute on internal representation, but
to unveil and dissect the hidden
assumptions in the debate. So it's kind
of like deploying FEP into the
representation debate. It's not going to
be the judge, it's going to be like some
other role. What is the FEP in that
setting? Six, another lesson learning is
that some traditional polarizations
might be attenuated or dissolved under
the FEP. So here we're seeing multiple
uses of the free, which is why there's a
bunch of different colors on here. It's
a theoretical plurality. It has also
a plurality of applied models. It's a
mirror, it's a bit hedge.
It's a unifier with traditional
polarizations like cognitiveist versus
an activism. And then here's a really
fascinating part. Zhat I know many
people in the lab will be excited to
talk about the FEP advances a unified
view where terms that traditionally
belong to different ontologies can be
harmonized. So it's an ontological
unifier. For example, modeling and
expectation is not used in some of the
works that talk about autopoeysis and
synchronization. Eight how
does the FEP do this? It begins with a
strong inactivist flavor and a focus on
action that's missing from traditional
cognitive theories. So by starting with
1ft squarely in action, it brings
something that a lot of neurocognitive
theories are missing from and then
extends the scope of an activist
thinking to territories of, for example,
counterfactual thinking and model
selection and abductive logic like we
talked about also with Beni. So it's
kind of like coming from action landia
and bringing in inference and then
starting from inference landia and
bringing in action. Almost like it's
called act of inference or that's like a
related idea or something. And then the
9th sentence is just saying the space of
the possible is big and we're going to
have to reduce our uncertainty by making
it happen. So it's a really great
conclusion.
Any other comments on Zhat Bleu? Just
pretty epic paper. I think it ties
together a lot of stuff we've talked
about. Stuff we will talk about. Yep.
Okay, final things and things to discuss
in dot one and two. Okay, so here is a
quote from the paper where they say
given the FEP has been implemented in a
family of computational models that are
by definition fully observable,
that's the first part to highlight. So
in Zhat sense, are computational models
fully observable or what does
observation mean for models? What does
explainability mean or transparency
mean? Is that reproducibility? Is that
perturbability? Is the map fully
observable? Is the territory fully
observable? Are there settings where one
or the other or neither or both are
variable? So what is this visual
metaphor and what are some of the
nuances with like observation and visual
perception? And then here is FEP
as a unifier. So it's
less surprising if one considers FEP
unites notions that are generally
considered antithetical some meaning
like contrary to each other, most
notably the notion of internal
generative model, which is usually
associated with representationalist
theorem, and autopoeicis, which is
usually associated internal
representation inactive approaches.
So I think just who
considers which notions antithetical?
Some classic examples area provided
here, like To, Helmholtz and Maturana
and Area. But just who
disagrees and why? And what can we learn
by just hearing different perspectives
on some of these debates? And then how
is representation related to
autopilotis? So autopoetic
systems are those that are variable of
producing and maintaining themselves by
creating their own parts. It's kind of a
classic complexity idea and
it made me think about poetic naturalism
and then all these other proposals like
the metapoetic naturalism and stuff.
And then there were zero Google hits for
autopilotic naturalism. But I think
it's very related to what we spoke
about with Majeedni and science as
modeling in the world and about, of
course, the title of this paper and the
representations questions.
So this is just a very provocative
paragraph that brings a lot of ideas.
In Bleu it's also just the middle way,
right? Is it this or that or maybe some
combination of these two things? Is the
right thing the depth perception,
as Dean says? So then one more sort of
general comment and then we'll go to the
specifics to discuss next time. So this
is the FEP as mirror. So one can use the
debate on representation in FEP the
other way around, not as a way to
resolve the issue at stake, but as a
mirror to look at one's own implicit
notions of representation. So here's a
paper that I wrote with my colleague
Eirik Sovik in 2019, where we talked
about scientific theories for
consciousness. And so instead of using
a model of consciousness for granted,
like integrated information theory or
some other quantitative measure of
consciousness, we took the system as
the recognition, which was an ant
colony, and then reflected
back on different scientific theories of
consciousness, what Zhat Majid about,
what people value, about, for example,
anatomical versus functional linguistic
behavior, components of systems. And so
we talked about like forward tests,
where you're good with your tests,
you've got a calibrated instrument. And
so this is like what the bulk of the
literature review was in the first half
of this paper, which was like, we're
just going to go with the FEP as what
our framework is, and then we're going
to assess there's still a diversity of
perspectives on representation, even if
you think the FEP is totally the Goto
theory. So this does not mean that you
eliminate ambiguity. It just means that
you're using your tool in a deployment
oriented way versus the reverse test,
which is like taking things that are
known in the world or some sort of
internal preference data and then
shining it back as a mirror on the
test and comparing amongst tests, which
also does, of course, recurs because
it's a test being applied to do so. But
that's where the real revolutionary
science happens. And so this paper
by Pezzulo and Sims showed
both modes in total harmony.
And so I think it's an awesome
contribution from velocity of science
perspective. So I look forward to
talking about that and about Ford and
reverse tests. And then here's a bunch
of other stuff. What are you excited
about here? >>>BLEU: Bleu this is just stuff I
wrote down to talk about, like cell. I
was just taking notes while we were
talking today about what might be cool
to discuss in the one and two a lot
about the sensory motor loop, mental
engagement, mental action. Does. That
trigger the same kind of biological
response as an actual action,
and then the idea of thinking through
other minds versus multiscale
integration, what might be similar or
different there, and the independent
evidence of the FEP? Or is it just a
mere we hold up? Maybe for ourselves,
but I think that this paper was
provocative and great. I have been a big
fan of Tesla for a long time. More
recently a Matt Sims fan, but probably
I've been reading Pazilla's papers for
ten years and excited to have the chance
to really dissect a paper by him with
more than just myself. Great.
Well, glue. >>>DANIEL: Thanks a ton for the awesome
work on the dot zero. I think we were
trepidacious to jump into this paper,
but then you were prediction no
problem. I got it. I'm processing it's.
True. >>>BLEU: That's easy. Yeah, we got it.
One week, sure. Three days for double
zero. We got it. We're good. I read a
long time ago also. Yes. We just hope
that anyone who wants to ask a question
can. Even if it's long past the one two.
>>>DANIEL: If you're listening to this in time,
then congrats. And you should definitely
get involved conversation and otherwise
we'll see you around the lab. So thanks
again, Bleu, and thanks everybody, for
watching. See you later. Thanks.